There are a few ways that you can build
up tension in a movie scene through
camera work,
through pacing,
and probably most commonly through
music,
like the music you're hearing right now
in this incredibly tense scene from
Steven Spielberg's,
2005 film Munich,
except there is no music in the seat,
but I'm getting ahead of myself.
Let's back up.
We all know that movies have only two
ways into your brain through your eyes
and your ears,
but if you've ever had the chance to
edit a movie or a short film or even a
small video,
it quickly becomes apparent that when
you're watching something,
these two senses are weirdly
interconnected.
The visual side of film gets most of the
attention because it's right in front of
you and it's usually what you remember
after a movie is over,
but in many ways the visuals are simply
the face of the operation.
While the audio is actually the puppet
master,
the one that really holds them
power.
Okay?
Let me show you what I mean.
Take a look at this scene right here.
So what does Spielberg want you to pay
attention to?
Hear these people walking by and this
car passing,
no,
it's not what Spielberg wants.
It's what I want.
Since that was the sound design I just
made for that shot.
Here's what the actual shots sound stuff
still,
besides
being infinitely better,
it's easy to notice how the sound really
affects what you see and from what
perspective you see it.
In my version,
the shot had an omniscient third person
point of view in the real version.
As soon as the audio starts,
you're placed in a perspective.
The first thing you hear is a
conversation from street level,
so even though the long lens is fixed on
Eric Bana,
you know the moment is taking place on
the ground.
Then to drive the point home,
you hear Daniel Craig singing the
temptations and the vocal recording is
close,
intimate.
Even though you never go inside the car,
that's enough to put you there.
Then the car that you're really supposed
to pay attention to,
the black one parks and the sound of it,
parking jumps out in the mix.
Just like you wouldn't hear Daniel Craig
in that way from where the camera is.
You wouldn't hear the car that clearly,
but the sound design picks these things
out to tell a specific story.
Still stays shut up.
The point here is that in film you
really do see with your ears more than
you think and sound doesn't mind.
That image gets the credit because a key
to the power of sound design is its
invisibility.
If dialogue sounds close than you are
close to the person who's speaking it
wherever they are.
My brothers would choose my Papaya and
my sister were both hanging.
Okay,
so back to the sequence.
Oh yeah,
forgot.
No music
for a minute and 52nd seat is without
music and almost entirely wordless.
How does Spielberg and legendary sound
designer Ben Burtt who gave the world
this?
How do they build the tension here?
Well,
burt does it by building a bed of
constant noisy city ambiens.
Then singling out and stringing together
like beads on a wire.
Key noises that tell the story.
The background is that Eric Bana and his
team are going to assassinate this man
and his home by getting him to answer a
phone that they've secretly installed a
bomb in the string of isolated plot.
Sounds goes like this.
The car with the assassins arrives the
dialogue of the targets wife and
especially young daughter than their car
pulling away signaling it's safe to move
forward.
Then the coins and rotary phone that
will make the call then the priming of
the detonator
and then wait,
what was that
first moment of trouble comes in south.
Up until now,
the isolated noises represent the steps
of the plan going smoothly.
The truck passing by represents a break
in that chain and a hitch in the plan.
At this point,
the ambience outside starts to take on
some strange qualities.
There's a high pitched whine like a
train stopping on top of everything,
and just like the moving truck blocks,
the assassins view,
the movers talking keeps them from
hearing the daughter's car pull back up
to the apartment.
She plays a key part in the scene.
So burt isolates her again,
but not her voice this time.
Her footsteps,
which continue indoors in the apartment,
the ambiance is quiet,
and the really incredible thing about
this scene is that Burton Spielberg
build the tension not by working toward
a great crescendo of noise,
but by gradually subtracting elements.
Once the daughter is up here,
the danger can be signaled by a single
sound.
Okay,
perfect.
The important elements have been set up
so well by this point that you could
follow the rest of the scene without
seeing it at all.
All right.
Hello.
I know
the climax of this scene brilliantly is
silence,
but it's the silence that works so well
because it anticipates the noise of an
explosion to come.
At this point.
The ambience has become really
impressionistic and when it comes back
in,
it has echo and reverb.
It's hurried footsteps and an anxious
siren.
The wholesale universe corresponds in a
personal way to the assassins,
to their feelings and their nerves,
so it makes sense that when the final
question is asked,
it's the sound design that answers the
off.
I'm not sure what they're doing in film
school these days,
but if you have any interest in making
movies
at all,
you shouldn't attempt to make a scene
like this.
No dialogue,
no music,
just camera work in sound design.
Once you finished it,
watch the scene back.
Close Your eyes and ask yourself,
what are your ears?
See?
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching and
welcome to the first video of 2018.
That is really exciting.
Just finished my little recharge,
break over the new year,
which was wonderful and I'm ready for
the marathon.
That will be this year.
As always,
I want every nerd writer video in 2018
to be an event for you guys.
I want it to be something that really,
really stands out in your subscription
box and I'm going to work very hard to
make that happen for you guys.
Oh,
I almost forgot.
New nerdwriter mugs.
Super exciting.
The mugs are back.
Check them out at the store.
You'd find the link below in the
description.
You can see them right here,
there.
Super Cool.
So one of those of you guys want to
drink some coffee out of a nerd writer
mug.
That's cool.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That just makes that process of making a
website so simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever.
And picking your domain name,
whatever you want it to be is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thank you so much for watching this
show.
Subscribing being with me in 2018.
This is going to be a fun year.
See you next time.